so andrew allen is a writer he wrote the
rush series battlefield rush and he
plays a game a game that's introduced to
us by jan actually but andrew embraced
it wholeheartedly and the game is that
when you arrive at somebody's house or
really when you change location there's
a nerf fight that occurs anytime andrew
comes over he's packing
so we need to be ready
to answer the call that's how you killed
all of us well nerf killed all of us
we have this nerf mine that we built we
could string it up at the front door
leave the front door open and as long as
some other person doesn't walk into the
building
probably get them yeah that'd be great
huh like actually use a nerf mine like
functionally especially when you put it
on the internet and everyone gets to see
him get hit by a nerf mine how
embarrassing oh man he's gonna he's
gonna have egg on his face
how's this energy level like this
post-snap energy level for a vlog
i pride myself on my nerf tactics close
we'll run the string
we'll do a clear fishing line across the
doorway just leave it open we're going
to hide
we need to record it without getting
seen we all need to be just out of view
oh i know we can do sure you don't just
keep filming me doing this for the next
hour
[Music]
this 360 camera is the insta 360 one not
361 degrees but 360
one plugs into your iphone i don't know
if they have an android version you do
all the processing and stuff on your
phone i hold your phone upside down and
boom it works
we've seen this before from the first
insta360 camera it just hooks up
directly to your phone you can see a
live preview right from your phone so
hey look at that
it's a little nick 360 nick notice that
there's a cool feature on this that i
haven't seen
ever in any 360 camera but it's a
feature that i've thought about for a
very long time and that's to be able to
basically
recapture
the image after the fact in video mode
in video mode it's kind of hard to
describe what i'm talking about so
imagine like so a 360 camera right it
captures everything around you and
that's generally meant to be viewed in
like a vr headset or with your phone
looking around but you're only really
looking at a small portion at a time now
what if instead you wanted to just
export out a uh 16x9 image for like your
computer screen but this way you can
actually be really find in where you're
looking so it's like being able to
reframe an image after the fact but with
your field of view i'm gonna just do a
quick test here
i'm just gonna record a quick video
i can go all the way over here to hang
out with cool so here's the video i
literally just recorded pull it up right
here 360 image i can scroll through it
like i want you know standard 360 video
sort of stuff you can like move the
screen but here's something that's
really cool that i've never seen in a
360 camera before i have the ability to
do what's called free capture and that's
where i am literally just using my phone
frame up new shots and zoom in and out
as i want to even like zoom out to make
a really crazy wide field of view image
this is a yeah this is a second video
file that you can make looks like you're
holding a dslr so what you're saying is
cameramen in the future don't have to
choose their angles they can just can
you imagine that yeah like so imagine
360 cameras get so good that even really
zoomed in it still looks as good as
let's say this camera right here zoomed
in eventually the cameras will become
higher resolution which will mean that
the crops themselves will be much higher
quality and eventually you might even be
able to get bokeh that you get from a
nice quality lens i mean just look at
the pixel 2 or the iphone they have
portrait mode which that basically adds
fake depth of field using fancy sensors
and algorithms they're able to actually
fake really good looking depth of field
and imagine one day with a 360 camera
that's a 16k video portrait mode enabled
you won't ever need a regular camera
anymore you'll just walk around with one
of these 360 cameras be able to pull
snippets from that 360 image that looks
just as good as a regular dslr and a
nice lens today and you never miss a
moment no longer problems where you're
looking at the wrong thing at the wrong
time wait i mean that's the problem for
us because there's a group of people and
you can only look one direction but if
you can look at all the directions at
the same time you'll never miss another
moment there'll always be a time and a
place for regular cameras with specific
needs but a 360 camera that can capture
everything and deliver the same quality
as a regular dslr with depth of field
and good audio it's like that is not too
far-fetched and it's coming soon start
saving your money because it's coming
next fall
i mean not really but it's really cool
that insta360 is experimenting with this
obviously there's a lot of improvement
but it's pretty good as it is right now
you made a movie
the movie is done are you ready which
movie
which movie
tales of the american oh the one that we
shot the drones for you bet it's done it
comes in the director's cut comes in at
2 hours and 40 minutes so here's what
you're going to see when you go to the
movie theater on november 30th at the
downtown independence you guys i'm gonna
sit get you guys seats
here's what you're gonna see you're
gonna watch one hour and 20 minutes
worth of movie
and then
the words intermission you're going to
have a 20-minute intermission
it will be
four songs from the musicians that are
have done the soundtrack for the movie
the each one of them's got a song okay
so it's jesse easter jake labotts
lightning woodcock and the devil dog so
you can get up take pee buy another beer
then the house lights will dim like
three minutes before you get your back
into the seats then watch another hour
and 20 minutes of moving it moves like a
it moves like a freight train it moves
it moves it moves we just we kept those
cuts going there's nobody's ever on the
whole thing longer than maybe
um 12 seconds started shooting oh god
november 30th of 2013.
god it's been a project i will i i've
i've i've already got more ideas and
more for more projects and stuff
tomorrow we're doing the posters and i'm
also starting to make phone calls and
get people lined up so
i hope you guys are in town on november
30th yeah congrats man i know i know
what we're doing right now pam's in the
editing room putting on the title
credits already screened it at the
downtown independent just for us we did
a technical screening wanted to watch
the whole thing would it look like on
the big screen i'm telling you right now
gopro
7d
5d looks great it looks great this guy
you know he's got state-of-the-art this
guy at the downtown event has state of
the art and the [ __ ] sound is
incredible the music is incredible i was
shocked i was shocked at how many
different kind of cameras we shot with
and how good it looks yeah and that adds
so much production value to
anything you do drone shots i don't know
how you can do a movie nowadays without
one in it
hey napoleon
give me one year talk no man
first things first
go outside and tell me if you can even
see this yeah
oh i have an idea
like right here
[Music]
so maybe you put it up higher
pronounce it here oh yeah you can
totally get away with this
[Applause]
you know i don't have a lot of
experience setting up traps in real life
it's one of those things you always
think about as a kid like yeah making
traps i really enjoyed home alone it's a
great movie i watched it with my cousins
back when it came out back when i was
really young and if you remember
there's a scene where he puts nails in
the stairwell
so they put some nails in the stair
while they step on it and my cousins and
i thought that would be hilarious to put
nails in the sidewalk so somebody could
step on one and get trapped
he's such a good friend
we're really young we didn't know that
much better found a bunch of nails
and we pounded them into the cracks in
the sidewalk sticking upside down
sticking up
and then we hid in the bushes and
watched as people would walk down the
sidewalk oblivious the fact that there's
freaking metal spikes sticking up
not noticing
i'm like remember there's this one dude
like this big guy with a big beard and a
big beard gut like walking on the tower
oh if that guy like steps in the nail
we're going to get ourselves kicked and
like then we like hid but he didn't step
on a nail so there's this woman pushing
a stroller she's pushing the stroller
and the stroller actually runs over one
of the nails and bends it she doesn't
notice and then she actually steps on a
nail and she stops and doesn't go
through her shoe thankfully like
out of all the things that pick up at
least you didn't actually hurt her she
steps on the nail
stop she looks down and she shoots the
shoe up and she has the nail stuck in it
and then she looks on the sidewalk
there's nails all over
sticking up
us being kids suddenly like realized
that that would really hurt and that we
could really hurt somebody and so i kind
of like
step out and like look at her she's like
did you guys do this i'm like yeah we
did that
you're coming with me right now where
where's your mom like which house are
you from where's your mother like this
one and like we kind of just turned
ourselves in and we walked in ran down
here i'm telling the story i'm just i'm
i'm kevin you're interrupting me get out
of here
get that one fly away
[Music]
she knocks on the door and my aunt opens
it and she's like what's going on she's
like they put nails in the sidewalk and
she's my aunt was so soft at us
so she immediately like you guys are
done playing nico you're out you guys
you're grounded and i had to go back to
my grandmother's house she was
understanding she's like you're just a
kid you didn't know any better home
alone is a good movie i'm like yeah
[Applause]
needless to say
i not think about the consequences of my
actions more
it's pretty good i can't really see it
when your light's not shining at it okay
so they say okay i i activated triple
switch and in principle
what what happens is that it takes a
really really high speed it takes a high
speed video as i'm swinging it about
myself and then it plays it back in slow
motion so you swing this around yeah
let's
let's go over here this is like
literally the jankiest manual that came
with the camera saying swing the camera
around on a string careful not to hit
anything
uh so that's right
[Music]
feels good out here
[Music]
why don't you just chill
why don't you just chill out
why don't you just chill out and listen
listen
got things on your mind that worry you
keep you awake no i just don't sleep
much
you don't sleep i don't sleep i
[Music]
to if it died don't sleep revive this so
it thrives through and as long as we
alive too this is michelin star in the
kitchen no drive through that flow chef
in it a1 prepping it tiff's got a bottle
on that most definite [ __ ] can't
question it it's always wrong like the
sun gonna shine we just always are like
y'all can't see what we always saw we
was never up close we was always far now
we almost here neither here nor there
every [ __ ] fear no man nor a fear no
fear i got no [ __ ] left to give one
dream gun too big can't tuck in my jeans
everyday hustle never touch anything and
you wonder how i'm balancing weight with
one team
it's a mouse click
[Music]
all right
we'll see yeah i mean i it didn't work
inside because there wasn't enough light
but it's it spins like this really
really fast so i might still get motion
blur i don't know yeah let's find out
that's the point of an experiment right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my god guys i totally didn't know where
you were
did it work though did he just run
through it or what i don't know if he
got hit or not we'll have to review the
computer it may like i'm not gonna say
it's impossible that hit me but i didn't
feel anything
and then i was looking for parking and i
pulled through and i just saw all of you
standing here and i was like oh those
tricky devils
and then alex uh told me where you were
so alex
what's up alex
you're so fast
oh man
dude just breezes by it i was like so
what's going on in there oh they're back
in the back they're in the room and i
was like okay good what's the best of
the speed of the president like the
whole tunnel vision thing totally worked
but yeah
you think you did with a real mind just
run really fast
i think that sucks is that i almost had
you and i missed you by like oh and then
i went in and missed you again and then
he just got me right in there man
christian was prepared he was i'm always
ready man